for the first time a major feature film
is shedding light on the life of Harriet
Tubman she became an icon of freedom in
the face of the Underground Railroad
Tubman made 13 trips over ten years
leading more than 70 people to freedom
the movie Harriet chronicles Tubman's
escape from slavery and how she became
an underground railroad conductor
Cynthia Revo plays Harriet Tubman after
arriving in Philadelphia Harriet meets
abolitionists and Underground Railroad
leader that's William still played by
Leslie Odom jr. we know him - Harriet
soon wants to go back south to rescue
her family
rescuing slaves requires skill and
careful planning
it requires reading Harriet can you read
a sign or map can you read it all put my
attention on trying to hear God's voice
more clearly do you know what would
happen if you got caught they would
torture you until you pointed them right
to this office you got lucky Harriet and
there's nothing more you can do don't
you tell me what I can do tell her what
she can't do the same Cynthia rivo and
lesson Odom join us let's see Odom jr.
join us here at the table good to see
you both I have to say I was a little
embarrassed because when I started
thinking about Harriet Tubman I thought
I really don't know anything she was a
leader of the Underground Railroad she
was a conductor I knew that she was a
small woman but I didn't realize the
physicality of what you had to do so I'm
wondering how you prepared physically
and mentally for this role Cynthia I'm
so I was I was training before we start
- getting to say I you know I'm a
fitness fanatic so I went at it really
hard and I made sure that I had like I
spend by cuz I wanted to keep up my
stamina was-- we were on set so I was
working out the hour before I would get
on set as well so that I didn't have to
play catch-up whilst we were doing all
those things because the stunt work is
me yeah and so and and I one thing that
was really wonderful about learning
about her is that she had a deep
connection to her spirituality
I guess that gave me the space to look
at mine to go in to go in and
you know be bit braver with my faith and
say my prayers and really like I guess
embrace it yeah that was really helpful
to to create the space for girls right
this is a figure from history you think
you know a little bit about but there is
so much more to know what surprised you
the most in learning about this
character I think it was that that that
it was really her faith and what she
believes that were God's directions to
to the way that she needed to go and I I
didn't know that that was such a huge
part of her story yeah that and the fact
that she was ingenious she was the one
that hired the lawyer she saved the
little bits of money that she would get
from being hired out to hire the way who
drew out the papers that her that proved
that her mother was supposed to be free
when she was 45 and then using song to
what was safe to go out different tempos
Oh did yeah so depending on the verse
that would tell you where you were
supposed to be whether it was time to go
when she was leaving when she was there
yeah and Lesley the first time you know
a little bit about playing historical
figures you were in Hamburg yeah and why
did this story which is such a critical
part of history do you think take so
long to get to the screen hmm I think
for a long time there was this data
around Hollywood that you know stories
about black life didn't make money
certainly stories starring
african-american women wouldn't make
money nationally or internationally and
I think more recently we have data
finally that really really proves that
you know to not be true so we're seeing
our stories being being told on the
large screen which is which is amazing
yeah I know one Harriet Tubman expert
described her as bad bold beautiful and
black she was a super hero before we
even knew superheroes they described her
as that that days Serena Williams so
what did it mean to you to play her and
you certainly know that you've gotten a
little blowback people have been
drinking cups of haterade because you
are British saying why is she playing
that role number one I want to know did
that hurt your feelings
and what did it mean playing her to you
I mean I'm human so you know those
things you can't not have them affect
you but at the same time I completely
understand it I knew it
well yes because we don't get to see
these stories very often where we get to
to ourselves that if there are very few
and far between where there's a woman of
color in the center of the story in the
period piece during action and fully
rounded it doesn't happen very often and
there's this woman that means a lot to
everyone well no disrespect to Kate
Winslet but it's not like if they if
they cast Kate Winslet a white woman
British is Harriet Tubman I could see
the outcry but I really didn't
understand the the criticism of you well
you know that the I think it's because
these characters are rare you know but I
I'm hoping that this simply means that
it's the first that that is made but
it's not the only one I hope it just
encourages more of these films because
we have plenty of Abraham Lincoln plenty
of Winston Churchill's but we definitely
need more Harriet Tubman so I hope this
is just like the first of very many
let's say you were saying this was a
different experience for you working on
this movie yeah I was talking about you
know we're talking a lot about the
patriarchy right now in society which is
you know overdue conversation that we're
having and this was really my first
experience I realized on set at some
point you know experiencing the
matriarchy and stuff yes form you know
what lead actress was a woman my
director my leap resort that feels not
better or worse but different yes you
know it's a vibe yeah how does it feel
different it's really not you know my
Hamilton experience was all men yeah nor
men let they expect you know I guess I
was just it wasn't that different I
guess you know what I mean but it's
different but it's but it's taken me you
know 20 years to have the experience you
know I mean it's yeah kind of thing you
like I heard the conditions were
grueling guys in Deborah Martin chase
who produced it said if Harry can get
through what she had gotten through that
many of you felt we can get through this
absolutely yeah I mean we at the other
end there would be someone with a coat
and we go back inside and we were fine
it was really powerful great performance
I'm so glad you did it Cynthia rivo and
Leslie Odom jr. we thank you
Harriet by the way is in theaters today